[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trade deadline later on today is Albert
Greer pointed out Monday Morning
Quarterback probably not a lot of action
going on at the trade deadline only
seven teams are more than two games
under 500 right now and uh the seventh
seed in the AFC the Chargers four and
three the seventh seed in the NFC is the
Niners at four and four
I gave you updated odds today and it
surprised some people uh obviously
Buffalo is your Super Bowl favorite
according to DraftKings then the Eagles
then the Chiefs the Niners are fourth on
that list at 13-1 Cowboys 15-1 and the
Ravens my Ravens slowly creeping up at
uh 18-1 after picking up roquan Smith
from the Bears Albert Breer the great
reporter lead content strategist for the
Monday Morning Quarterback who's buying
who's selling today Albert
well you know I I and I wrote this on
Saturday Dan um I think the past
professors are going to drive the
highest end of the market
um today and there are three in
particular the teams have made calls on
um that's Bradley Chubb from Denver uh
Brian Burns from Carolina and Josh Allen
from Jacksonville
um I you look at where those guys are in
their contracts that obviously has
something to do with it regime changes
um you know in all three places you know
I think plays into it as well uh but
it's not going to be cheap to get those
guys out of those places
um I would say in the case of Alan and
Chubb it's going to take at least a
first round pick probably more than that
and I think in the case of Brian Burns
it would take more than two first round
picks so
um if you want to pass rusher um I think
that those are the three that are sort
of the bells of the ball and if you want
to talk about teams that are out there
looking for pass rushers Rams Chiefs
Titans Ravens the Eagles still could be
they sort of already got their guy and
Robert Quinn but if the right deal comes
along
um you know Howie roseman's always
taking advantage of those sorts of
opportunities so I think you know if you
look at the very highest end of the
market that's what you're talking about
right now Kareem hunt
on the Move yeah I think that the Browns
are going to try
um to see if there's something out there
for him obviously he's in a contract
year
um and he wasn't happy with the white
contract negotiations went
um he would cost I think about a fourth
round pick so if there's a team out
there that's willing to give up before
to go and get him
um for you know half a season I think
that's something that that could get
done and we know the teams that have
been out there sort of sniffing around
running backs um the bills have been out
there sniffing around running backs the
Rams have been out there sniffing around
running backs
um you know that's another one that I
think Philly could be involved in
um you know obviously there was this
stuff out there with with them and
Camara and so
um I think that those would be sort of
the three teams that I would look at in
the running back Market
but I wonder you have certain teams and
you pointed this out that everybody's
sort of on the periphery you're kind of
in the mix and I got the Rams a buyer do
they still feel like hey we could get
obj back and we could trade for Kareem
hunt we we can still be a player in a an
NFC that seems to be a little more wide
open than the AFC yeah I think it's that
and it's also like just the window that
they're in um you know I know there's
probably some perception out there the
windows closed on them and maybe it has
you know but I I just know like the way
that they're operating right now is
they're all in on that group of four
players they have you know and Matthew
Stafford and Cooper cup and
um and Jalen Ramsey and obviously Aaron
Donald and when those guys are gone I
think there's a pretty decent chance
Sean McVeigh is going to be gone too so
you're not just talking about like
what's going to happen when you filter
those players out and building beyond
that you're also about talking about
potentially having to replace a coach if
it comes to that so you know I know some
people would look at it and say well at
some point they have to hold on to their
ones and they can't keep dealing their
picks away and all that and all of that
makes sense but why would make way go
why wouldn't he stay you know Pete
Carroll stayed around for yet another
rebuild there in Seattle
because I think at some point he's going
to take a break you know I I I just do
like knowing what I know I think he's
gonna at some point want to take a break
there's obviously going to be a lot of
money out there for him and television I
know he wants to kick the tires on that
um you know I I would say if I had to
Ballpark it I would say he has anything
he is anywhere between one and five
years left with the Rams and I do think
a big piece of this is going to be
dictated maybe the whole thing is going
to be dictated by those four players I
mentioned and the core of that team I do
not think that he's going to be sticking
right now this is again this is my
opinion but I I don't think he's going
to be sticking around for the Post
Matthew Stafford era of the Rams and I
mean I'll say this too we know Aaron
Donald probably only has a couple years
left right like we sort of have been
through that with him
um Cooper cup we'll see you know we've
got a lot of mileage now um he is still
under 30. so we'll see how long he can
go
um Jalen Ramsey is there
and I still I don't think I I just don't
think Stafford is going to be one of
these guys who hangs around till he's
40. I just don't you know he's pretty
beat up he's taking a lot of hits and so
you know could I see Matthew Stafford
being there maybe two three more years I
could see that that being the case too
so I think that's all kind of part of
why the Rams do feel urgency to build
right now because you know this is a
group that they've got for the here and
now and yeah it could get ugly after
that but you know while you've got those
guys in the building it makes sense to
maximize what you have and I I always go
back to when the Niners got Christian
McCaffrey how close the Rams were to
getting Christian McCaffrey and do we
know the details of yeah I mean I can
give you their offer if you want it the
offer the offer so the the the the
um the Niners got him for a two a three
a four in 2023 and a five in 2024. the
Rams offer was a two and a three and
twenty three a four and a 5 and 24 or in
cam Acres so the tie breaker there for
the Panthers was that fourth round pick
was in 2023 with the Niners and in 2024
with the Rams the reason for that is
because the Rams don't have a fourth
round pick in 2024 because last year
they traded it for Sony Michelle after
cam Acres got hurt so it's kind of
interesting the way all that ties
together with the running backs
um but they they the Rams put cam makers
in the package hope that that would put
them over the top and obviously it
didn't the Panthers wanted more picks in
the here and now and obviously that can
tie into to certain people's job
security you know like the general
manager Scott fitter does he know that
he's going to be around in 2024 you know
he doesn't know that like so if he knows
he's going to be bringing in a new coach
and working with a new coach it behooves
him to make them as competitive as he
can in 2023 there are a lot of moving
pieces there but that was the Rams offer
was
um a two and a three this year this
coming year 23 a four and a five in 2024
on Camp makers but you know we love to
follow there's a trend you know I always
go back to the greatest show on Turf
than everybody wanted to be like uh you
know the St Louis Rams there offensively
and when it comes to winning now the
Rams said here's the blueprint this is
what we're going to do we're going to
win now do the nine the Niners
subscribing to that uh Buffalo's
subscribing to that the Chiefs you know
that they're going to go all in to try
to win this year
yeah I do think teams are I think this
is an astute observation Dan like I I do
think teams are operating in Windows
more now you know what I mean like it
feels like okay we've got a certain
group of players that we can win with
and we need to do everything that we can
to win with those players while we still
have them because the nature of the
sport you know it takes a couple years
for a guy to hit his Prime and then how
long does he really have you know
um a guy who lasts like Von Miller has
lasted that's an outlier you know what I
mean like most guys like Star players
you have like a five or six year window
where they're gonna be you know like
giving you prime production and so if
you've got a couple of a bunch of those
guys hitting that window all at the same
time like what the Rams had then it
makes sense to maximize it and I think
that's where the Niners shift has been
they actually if you go back before the
Trey Lance trade like they were very
different than the Rams like they were
very conservative with their picks and
they weren't this team that was going
all in and it took them a little while
to build that core well now they have
that core that's where the shift in
philosophy is and so now if you're the
Niners you look at it it's like Debo
Samuel Brandon ayuke
um Trent Williams Nick Bosa Fred Warner
like that's why they're going all in now
because they've got like a crew of
players there that are right in the
prime of their career the same way the
Rams have and so they feel like it's
important that they capitalize on that
small crew of players now he's Albert
Breer the Monday Morning Quarterback let
me stay with the Niners if Jimmy
Garoppolo gets to the super I should
mention George Kittle too I wouldn't
want him to take it personally okay if
the Niners get to the Super Bowl with
Jimmy G
his future is what I
it's so complicated you know what I mean
like I
it would be interesting to see the
opportunity that's out there for him
because he's got such a good situation
now and you know assuming they get Debo
Samuel healthy now you're talking about
Debo Samuel and ascending Brandon IU who
I has been excellent right like and I
think is going to be a top 15 receiver
in the NFL with a little more time
um the best tight end in football
arguably all around tight end and
football and George Kittle and now
Christian McCaffrey behind you
and an offensive line that if it grows
up could wind up being one of the best
in football now it's going to be on
those three guys in the interior to grow
up yeah but what do you do with Trey
Lance
and that's the thing that the hard thing
about the trail last thing to me is they
were willing to go through this year and
do what it took to get answers on him
right like they wanted to have Clarity
by the end of this year and I know there
were people in that building who thought
like yeah like in July Jimmy Garoppolo
is a better quarterback but we think
that like by the time we get to December
and January Trey Lance will be the
better quarterback if that makes sense
right like so there was a feeling inside
that building that was if we give him
the time he'll get there we just got to
give him the time
are you willing to do that again you
know what I mean like and that's the
thing is like because of this injury and
it's really unfortunate it's like now
you you don't have those answers it's
not just him getting hurt it's the fact
that you don't have the answers that you
were trying to get to and can you get
those answers before you've got to make
these decisions in March probably not
right like so that's what's complicated
about this situation I still think
there's belief in Trey Lance in that
building and I still think they probably
go to Trey Lance in 2023
but I think it's more complicated now
and especially more complicated if Jimmy
plays well and remember
if Jimmy wants to take some of this
stuff personally and I think he's filed
some of it away you know
um yeah he has no tag clause in his in
his in his revised contract so they
can't stop they can't do anything to
stop him from getting to the market
I could see the Victory Parade if they
won the Super Bowl where they would have
Jimmy in his own car and just tell him
to keep driving you know it would be
perfect you know be perfect
if he went back to New England and there
was a quarterback competition between
Mac Jones and Jimmy garage
well there already is a quarterback
competition with Bailey zappy we could
have a three-way yeah that's exactly uh
give me the bad team that's in the best
position
bad team is in the best position
I really sort of starting to like where
the Bears are
I know that's probably not a popular
opinion you know it's not my bias to
Justin Fields
um but Fields has played better
they're competing their tails off I
don't know how much you've watched them
I watched them against Dallas I mean
they they made it interesting for a
while they fight right yeah like they
they fight like they and and you see it
like they're one of these teams if you
don't play well against them they'll
beat you you know and now we have a
little more context on the commanders
and that Thursday night game maybe the
commanders aren't as bad as we thought
they were and the bears were in it with
them you know so I just like sort of
look at like how young guys are buying
into the program and then I look at
where they're going to be after this
year they did pretty well in the draft
uh damn without having a first round
pick last year
um Jaquan brisker and and Kyler Gordon
and their secondary look like they're
going to be real players
and they get they're going to have three
picks in the first two rounds and seven
picks in the first five rounds and over
a hundred million dollars to spend in
free agency next year was a quarterback
that it look it looks like they're
starting to figure out how to use it and
it looks like he's starting to take
steps to getting better and so like
among the bad teams that are in the best
position I probably still put
Jacksonville number one because Trevor
Lawrence is Trevor Lawrence and I think
he's going to get there
but I think the Bears have sort of
entered the conversation there as a team
that's going to be really intriguing
going into 2023. who's your uh October
VP the MVP of October yeah I was I think
it was Todd that gave me the warning
about this so it's like that takes some
real thinking because like September
September's out the window on that right
yep got to be Josh Allen right I thought
Gino Smith might have been oh he knows
really good octo VP yeah I would go Josh
Allen it's the way he played in Kansas
City right like that that drive at the
end of the first half in Kansas city was
ridiculous and I don't think anybody
came out of like that game talking about
that tribe at the end of the first half
but what were they at the 10 right yeah
it didn't matter and that to me is like
when I when I look at Buffalo right now
it looks like they're playing with this
massive margin for for air that you
almost never see in the NFL like I think
I came on here
um you know in the summer and said the
bill sort of remind me in certain ways
the 07 Patriots and the 07 Patriots
played with that margin for error right
like it just felt like like Brady could
throw three picks in a game and it
wouldn't matter they were just that good
right and not that that happened but
like that was where they were
against the Packers everything looked so
easy for them and they they were
sleepwalking in the second half and Josh
Allen threw a couple he he used the word
bone-headed interceptions right and it
didn't matter and I just think like
things look so easy for them with Josh
Allen back there the way he's like
lifted up his teammates the way the Run
game's starting to get going now because
of him
I just think like you have to play the
Buffalo Bills a certain way now to have
any chance to get against them and so
much of that is based on who their
quarterback is they're a good team all
around and they've gotten better and I
mean it's insane to think that their
best defensive player hasn't played a
snap yet you know that's treadavius
white
um you know but like I just I look at
like what Josh Allen's done for that
place it's hard for me to go to any
other place but Josh Allen as my October
yeah exactly okay it's a little easier
November so so oh oh okay so you kind of
merged the end there yeah November
September October VP just is you know
I'm having some troubles I'm glad that
it's gone novembp uh I'll leave you with
this where do you stand on asking
questions that may not be directly
related to football like Tom Brady with
his divorce
it in a press conference setting or
sitting down with yeah Tom Brady
how much of that is a fair game
so I
it's a it's tough one
I think like their personal lives their
personal lives are their personal lives
until it starts to affect their
professional lives and when it affects
something that you're covering but how
do we know it's affecting him and that's
the thing that's the gray area and
that's why honestly
um that's such a big part of like what I
do is like in building relationships
with people
um you know I always tell people I you
know I'll say like if I have something
sensitive that I'm going to write I'm
going to come to you first and I think
too often we look at these things as
being confrontational when more often
than not I think what the reporter's job
to do is to do it's not just to grill
somebody is to give that person a chance
to give their side of the story and if
they don't want to give that side of the
story that's fine
um but there's also like a form to doing
that too and there's a way to do that
and if I don't have a relationship with
somebody then I'm probably more likely
to go and get after him in the press
conference on it and that's naturally
going to be a more confrontational
setting because of all the cameras and
all the people in the room and
everything else if I do have a
relationship with somebody I will always
pull that person aside if I have that
sort of question for him and ask him and
and not go right on the record that's
just the way I do it I'm not saying
there's any right way or wrong way to do
it but you know I I think treating these
people with empathy and as human beings
is such an important piece of what we do
and gets lost so often now in the way
the press conferences are being down to
the internet live and everything else
and everything becomes a meme and you
know I I just think you know like having
empathy for the other person in the
situation that they're in if you show
that
usually the person doesn't mind you
asking the question Tom Brady is with
the Buccaneers next year in TV or other
I'm tempted to say other I mean we
mentioned we talked about well wait
another team
I mean or I don't think it's impossible
like if this if the if this circles the
drain in Tampa because now he can play
that his his wife left him because he
wouldn't stop playing I will say this
like I've thought about the idea of San
Francisco right and like if they decide
Trey Lance isn't ready and Jimmy wants
to leave and Jimmy leaves like the
Niners have had this discussion the
Niners had this discussion this year
like like if if Tom was available to us
would we do it like they had this
conversation this year and the light was
sort of left on for that you know what I
mean like so
if you're San Francisco I mean I think
there's a competitive part of him that
like if the Niners
like decided we want to make a run at
Tom Brady with the core that we have and
we see how like the urgency with which
they've sort of built their team
you know like I think that would be
really tempting for Tom the problem now
is like what about the kids and I know
for all everything that's are you
talking about Trey Lance like what what
about the kids no no no no no no but but
I I do know like a major part of Tom's
decision to go to the Buccaneers not the
Chargers in 2020 was because he's got
his son jack lives in New York and it
would be much easier for him to get up
to see Jack on on on on on off days in
New York coming from Tampa than it would
be coming from LA
so like I think that that piece of it is
important to him as well and so I think
some of the idea of like him playing
again could be circumstantial based on
what is out there for him
um because I don't think like this is a
situation where he doesn't think he can
play anymore yeah like I think like he
probably believes that he could play it
46 years old
I whether or not he has the drive for it
I can't say I think he's the only one
that can say whether or not he wants to
do it that badly and I do think the
family part of it would be you know a
pretty significant consideration for him
and once again you're not reporting this
we're just you don't stick report colon
yeah
[Laughter]
good to talk to you Albert thanks for
joining us as always all right thanks
Dan that's Albert Breer senior NFL
reporter lead content strategist at the
Monday Morning Quarterback